yeah you know i've been in and out of
jail since i was like
for real for it you know i'm saying and
they just come and train like
certain things about me like you know
how i fold my clothes i
took my shirt in the way i eat my food
and you know just [ __ ] like this you
know what i'm saying what do you think
that's been out here
it just like down do it the same like
certain people could tell like i've been
locked up sometimes you know i'd be
trying to
distance myself from this [ __ ] they call
it being institutionalized
you know that's what i ain't i swear i
ain't but then you know people are
around me
some of my hoes especially my mama she's
swerving down a [ __ ] institution
how far are you going in school i got my
ged i i dropped out in the
ninth grade though
yeah after the ninth grade this [ __ ] was
all the way i was in my big brother was
deep in the street sometime out
here the reason i'm a gangster you know
i was in but he had a pimp bone in his
body he really was a sucker for a whole
you know what i was saying he hard on a
[ __ ] but when he come to a beach
mine take him down through though you
know what i'm saying
how'd you grow up you had both parents
or my dad was the primary
primary or what you want to say primary
caregiver however you want to say that
she
my mama was only hard yeah she smoked
the crepe
you know i'm saying she was a hustler
though bonafide hoe too
you know what i was saying a real
hustler though you know what i was
saying
the first my first [ __ ] my first viewer
memory of my mama she taught me how to
roll little socks and stuff
stuff in my opinions you know what i was
saying i was there me
my little brother jazz but reached their
peace my g.i.p
my little brother did me him my uncle
charles and my mama you know what i'm
saying we used to go through the stove
my burlington little tj makes jealous
all this [ __ ] today mouth out she used
to say y'all been that little
[ __ ] touch y'all mama
you know i'm saying so before i even
start hustling before i even start
pimping you know i'm saying anything i
was security
you know i was in you know i was in my
mama neighborhood he wrote everybody in
the mitchell height being hell no my
mama
you know what i'm saying you say me
share her nine rings a thousand billion
you know what i'm saying so i was always
around different little scenes you know
what i'm saying playing paper with the
texas and
you know what i'm saying the car fraud
sheet you know i'm saying real bonafide
hoe cause my mama was a
certified hold on time out hunting i ran
from here to albuquerque you know i was
ain't like for real you know what i'm
saying
and my dad was a squirrel you know i was
in country boy from griffin george
mama put their puss on fed talking
and she blew in mine they ain't no
having five keys
you know my mama got nine all together
fired by my dad and my daddy got killed
shot and killed
over a hoe you know what i'm saying yeah
over a hole when i was like
seven seven eight years old
and then when my life just took a dress
to change you know what i'm saying
like i probably wouldn't not be here
like in this state right here i'd
probably be a college educated ass
squirt choir boy or something [ __ ]
with my pocket did how serious he took
out up bringing wood you know what i'm
saying
versus coming back here with shannon who
my mom like
it was it was night and day you know
what i'm saying
like she embraced the streets you know
again so it wasn't no keeping around it
would
get up out of her type [ __ ] go outside
and play don't go in your room
take your ass outside and play so with
that you know
i mean if it's a [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying like
it's either get eight out of here you
know what i'm saying so
one thing i had a natural inclination
tool
was like i caught on quick you feel like
i was observing i asked a lot of
questions what's that for
why you caught the gun like that why you
load the bullets like this why you cut
it like this when you put
heat on what why you put baking soda
with like i
always ask a thousand questions you know
what i'm saying to the point where i
have to [ __ ] up sometimes you know what
i'm saying come on you can't be in the
car asking questions
you know what i'm saying you're right
gangsta killer rob myrtles
you carry a gun yeah always oh where's
your gun
he's close
you guys started in the game when
i was part of the game like you telling
me i'm strictly pimping
strictly pimping mine you know my baby
mama mine that's the first [ __ ]
introduced me to the game
like i'm telling my life my whole my
dough
you know what i'm saying my spot like
she will you know i'm saying i hit
shot a [ __ ] pearl so
i was fighting a little charge and [ __ ]
i was on a 90 thousand dollar bomb
really like ain't got a pocket piece in
the window to throw it out of
you know what i'm saying and one thing
about my whole crystal mine she always
wanted the bed for dad
she told she brought it to me straight
like these mine if i could show you that
i can make more money
in one night than you said and dope when
you put the sand down
she peeked my in something like bj and
show me you know what i'm saying
my man i'm like i'm gonna cut these
little cad from this whole and steel
work to say
but my money was so sweet
it was so [ __ ] sweet when i saw that
she just talked to his mind
i'm somehow talk shining [ __ ] his mind
you know
just off this conversation yeah
didn't mind coming down with this bread
is that easy you know what i'm saying
it's it's that simple okay then we
shouldn't make a lifestyle out this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
and from this day forward man you know i
didn't dab
with the sick you know what i'm saying
fire hooks and sitting rocks weed all
this [ __ ] i dibble and dab
but my mind occupation with pimping and
pendulum you know what i'm saying i
can't be
anything about me you know what i'm
saying
you don't so you're in prison time you
just got out
recently july how many years ten years
three
ten years three months before my uh
attempted myrtle position widow
intention manufactured to live with seal
to a pinnacle facility because when i
was locked up i was still trying to get
it in
you know i was there i ain't got an
extra like
2.7 for the two years six months for
this [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] i just got out from this
[ __ ] you know i said i went i got locked
up in 2010
i first he copped the charge in 2007 so
i fought it
for three years you know i was in
running back and forth
in and out the state you know what i'm
saying that she finally had caught up
with me i was on a hundred and feet a
thousand dollar bone
pimping and painting like no i'm saying
my whole crystal the same one
you know i'm saying i ain't with the
beast in that mind but she failed a
whole spot in my heart though you know
what i'm saying a special spot in my
pocket
no one's ever
2010 and she i ain't see another day
like to [ __ ] july recently
all right and she even in their mind
still with the same thing
you know i'm a street [ __ ] first and
foremost so
you know i want finna just get in jail
and just
you know turn into no we call them
penetration [ __ ] you know i'm saying
it's a term did we use
we refer them all for this
institutionalized the term that i spoke
on earlier you know what i'm saying
and i want you to be there man you ought
to see them [ __ ] in their mind you
know what i'm saying treatment over a
soap stamp a bowl of soup
you know i'm saying life don't amount to
[ __ ] they care about the smallest things
but
being in a pressure cooker situation
it'll make you cry about this [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying [ __ ]
steal a pearl saxon you know what i'm
saying
miss miss this place should come and see
you reform you don't get no food [ __ ]
like that well
you know she smiles [ __ ] like they end
up you'll get stabbed forward you know i
think
so today you have how many girls i got
four currents
i'm saying jazz and jessica i called my
little white [ __ ] panda bruh she got
some a's in them
you know what i'm saying i got my bottom
[ __ ] hungry you know i'm saying
you know how she healed her to deal with
but she take her to bed and like only
she can man
you know what i'm saying but you know
it's good always to have another bottom
[ __ ]
in the making if you can't let no hoe
get too comfortable man
you know what i'm saying feel like she
got you all the way to the point where
she got you
you know i'm saying when i feel like she
know anything about her pimp she want a
new one
you know what i'm saying hoe wanna hear
something new go someplace new
be shown something new worth something
new feel new i don't wanna know oh
how are you so bad how easy is it
honestly for a girl to get out
if she wants to to get out of the game
yeah or to leave with him
you know me mine
it's all about the pimp you feeling it's
all about the pill man
how far you want to go you know what i'm
saying with me mine you know i deal with
choice not fourth and i used to deal
with four's not choice you know i'm
saying hence the gorilla fred on my knee
you know what i'm saying
i usually be hard on a whole you know
what i'm saying my way or the highway
now i'm a little bit i guess i i a
little bit lengthy
the 10 years of duty though you feeling
what i'm saying
i was in 10 years it mine made me a
little bit more
understanding but the but the gorillapin
style
with a girl who may want to get out
means what
i mean ain't no getting out with gorilla
[ __ ] what i say it is you know what
i'm saying for how long i see it here
you know what i'm saying
and you can go and pray about the tear
god [ __ ] you could tell the devil
ain't gonna change you know what i'm
saying so
you know and then you know me my
too much physical [ __ ] every time i look
up i gotta slap this whole eject this
[ __ ] up or
all right look man it got to be a better
way you feel
so i wanted to master my crab because
before i went to jail
you know what i'm saying i was just you
know what i'm saying
my big toes was in the game you know
what i'm saying when i got out it was
full of fleas pimping another people die
with me
you know what i'm saying i ain't going
nowhere play ain't going no what a way i
ain't trying no word around this way
i'ma live in daddy's way
you know what i'm saying and once i
fully made their commitment
you know what i'm saying they humbled me
a little bit because i feel
like i knew more you know what i'm
saying i could accomplish more i ain't
have to go to your route you see what
i'm saying
see gorilla pimping really frustration
you see what i'm saying
it's right frustration you ain't got
enough game to tame the whole
you see what i'm saying a pimp game got
to be longer than this whole
money the [ __ ] your money hoe you hear
me i'm rich forever
you see what i'm saying but see being
articulated and masterful enough
you know what i'm saying to present it
that way you ain't going to get them
results
the results you want you see what i'm
saying and see when a pimp don't get the
results he won't they 10 in the first
grade will pimp fourth grader pen
whoop holes i would their first graded
pimp
you know what i was saying check my
rough screen plenty to miss the vibes
you know what i'm saying i'll put the
charge on a [ __ ]
and and it won't even kind of
preliminary right get that [ __ ] thrown
out i got about c major no more [ __ ] you
know what i was saying
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] man google me this
[ __ ] black and white on me you know what
i'm saying
it followed for like 17 all wheeled to
like
19 20. you know what i was saying
about 17 19 20. i was in when i bought
right before i stopped right before i
went to the penitentiary though
you know then she started simmering down
a little bit how i started dealing with
the whole because
so you know what i'm saying i wasn't
getting the results i wanted
so i'm like [ __ ] i can't keep i can't
keep
going through this [ __ ] leaving likely
she knows i remember vividly mine
it was 2009 mardi gras i was in new
orleans
me and my first whole crystal she my
baby mama too you know what i'm saying
it was me her on her friend no i'm
saying it was a new [ __ ]
you know i said yeah
i like moving sometimes yeah we can take
a break if you want to nah we're cool
all right we're cool
but we in the world
i'm saying my whole new to the game you
see
i said she probably had been home for
probably like eight months at the
time but she so goo guy once my whole
get a taste of their money man they just
worse as we like they get addicted more
than weed
you see what i'm saying so you don't
always be pimping and then be the proud
of mine
holby won't no hope some hoes wanna hold
they get a taste of this like mine
and get absorbed in it don't come out
consumed with it it becomes a life
you feel anyway i'm saying my whole
sleep new to this [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
tyrika she share what you call a vehicle
i hope they've been in the game been
working that trip being in and out of
state you know what i'm saying she ain't
no rookie at all
you know what i'm saying so this [ __ ] i
already dealing with this old bus that
is simple
[ __ ] ain't got a mountain out bust that
[ __ ] beat up
ain't got no car ain't got no gang you
know what i'm saying the [ __ ] just like
them
you know what i'm saying sometimes the
whole choose
not a lot of times the whole chooser but
i say this sometimes my whole make the
pill
you feel the any pimp will tell you my
the best pimp getting gained from a
whole
you feel and in this situation mine
sarika dealing with a
[ __ ] that she giving the game to and
ain't getting no gain from
you know what i'm saying it just ain't
no good situation and then here i come
in fresh out the gia
you know what i'm saying i'm on board
150 thousand dollar bond [ __ ] been
hearing about me caught a shot one at
home boy
you know what i'm saying he sleep don't
want to be in a car with me
sleep putting salt in the whole earth
you really yeah so we out of town in new
orleans and [ __ ]
oh then the [ __ ] get the argument with
the [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying something like
look check this out man look choose up a
little one [ __ ] this sucker you know
what i'm saying
him got to ride back with us you know
what i'm saying you can roll away it you
know what i'm saying leaving with them
bust ass shoes you found i mean
you feel i'm saying so my whole cd
my that was the first taste like
my whole see me getting at another whole
c4 for the longest
i just let the whole going knock all the
hoes i played the post you know what i'm
saying
now i get gorilla with the whole when
they bg me and them
you know what i'm saying i'll be getting
my point across and i'm gonna make him
understand me but for the most part g i
played the post
you know what i'm saying i worked my
whole day my whole work these hoes
you know i'm saying come play on ain't
one thing about new orleans they pimp
killers
you know what i'm saying i'm [ __ ]
gangsters and murderers down there dope
sellers and [ __ ] down that ain't with
that pimping [ __ ]
you know what they don't [ __ ] hit the
buddha club they just want to throw they
can see some ass and
you know what i'm saying this he you
know what i'm saying the whole first
told me
you can't be my boyfriend here i
you can't say you like we together i'm
like [ __ ] what you mean oh you mind
[ __ ] what you mean
she like naw they pill killers down here
for real dad you got to be this way
always listen to your ho ji yeah
i'm saying you're not gonna properly
listen to her man cause she gonna guide
you see him you gonna guide her she
gonna guide you that's how this [ __ ]
work
you know what i'm saying so that there's
a romantic connection with your girls
or just one of them too
the other two ain't no [ __ ] i never let
him eat the dick
now ain't never got a deep pick from a
pig you know
squiggly guys quickly did what it is you
know what i'm saying
but the other two you know i'm saying i
[ __ ] you know you know what i'm
saying i try to
you know what i'm saying like like you
got a master you look deep mine
you're me yeah you got to mine you know
what i'm saying
you don't mind i'm gonna put you in the
same category as a treat
you know what i'm saying this damn this
deal to a
yeah we ain't the same at all and don't
never miss the screw this [ __ ] don't
know
play with me like it is here but see
this on you though if you call the
[ __ ]
and when we call my mind racehaven the
whole
mind for one year you're gonna be a
broke pill you hear me
and two now you're gonna be a simple
chili pimp you hear me
i'm gonna treat you like anything i'm
gonna pay you when she wanna pay you
and that ain't what's going on that's
not what's going on peter
you know what i'm saying but you gotta
sit you gotta you gotta put your foot
down from the dope
you know it's in cause if you don't like
i said the whole gonna run all over you
but oh like mine fad flared big man
in the wood like i said the whole got
the arm with the [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying how to read the [ __ ] he writes
out the top [ __ ] you know you ain't my
cardinal
matter of fact both of these whole man
[ __ ] kick rocks right then
you know i was in and see that was the
first time my whole head seen me ever
take her for another whole
speak good on another hole in hoodie
and he made the whole jibbies what
what's what's the advantage of
working with a pimp for for the girl the
advantage of working with a pimple
why not just go renegade
[Applause]
oh my get cute well i'm saying it's just
the benefits that come with working with
you know i'm secured on protection you
know what i'm saying my name black and
gold in this street you know what i'm
saying i'm talking about from not meant
for this album if it's
to wear wood on man you know what i'm
saying fredro cinco no
you know what i'm saying so you know
this that's a little see i don't want to
be a part of some path she don't want no
ranking thinking
you're not coming through nah
local joke now man you know what i'm
saying
it's the difference between 513 and cnn
man
you see what i'm saying i want to go
around globe you see what i'm saying
oh no she can't do that with no average
joe blow ass [ __ ]
you feel you know what i'm saying that
why you got to come in my paper paint a
big picture
yeah i'm saying we see a dream well
you know what i'm saying and and we did
man you gotta always
make a whole field special make a whole
no [ __ ] a part or something powerful
you know what i'm saying i didn't see
any hoes purposely put themselves in
situations
to see if they're pimple saved to see if
they're [ __ ] gonna come through like
you say you're gonna do
and save you feel you oh try you like d
you know what i'm saying see if he about
what he talking about you know what i'm
saying
let me take this [ __ ] pocket check this
[ __ ] ooh you know what i'm saying
i'm saying so you know i always kind
correct you know i was thugging
since i've been off the push like i've
been out the porch like you know what
i'm saying i've been getting to a bag
i've been giving me some money before
the whole money
you know what i'm saying my whole
primary objective
with me was to get me to put the set
down
you feel she wanted me to stop sitting
hard stop
sitting softly you know what i'm saying
hand [ __ ]
man the whole really wanted
wanting me out to herself too you feel
that's another thing too man
you will find these old one pimp add one
i mean one hawaii
pimps you know what i'm saying wasting
their time time to
call the real sure and constantly
appease this [ __ ] and baby boo boo boo
boo boo
suck ass [ __ ] and get what
they're going to be the broken pimp you
ever seen your [ __ ] life really
now i ain't doing none of that man you
know what i'm saying i ain't doing none
of it and i peep there from it because i
went through the experience period
when i was 17 18 seeing how hoe trying
to
you know what i'm saying cut from y'all
to ourself you know what i'm saying them
on the spread they're pimping around you
know it was all good when she
when when i was letting her go and knock
out of the holes and talk for me and all
that but then when pimping stepped in
the line like you know what i'm saying
when they shot this [ __ ]
for real out of the whole clam up you
feel
you know i'm saying she won't read the
food you know what i'm saying because i
came on this other [ __ ] because it was
love for
you see what i'm saying so i said
it made something clear to me you see
you can't you can't turn a hole out
you hear me and have longevity with this
hoe
it just don't work like this because the
whole gonna feel portrayed you can't go
from dead to the bro
you see what i'm saying say
you turn the hoe out versus knocking the
hole that's already a full fledged hole
you see what i'm saying see what the
full fledged host
it pimp in front of dope you see what
i'm saying she know what it is
off the top you know what i'm saying and
anything and that's going to be on yo
you're going to be on your demonstration
how you come you see you alright versus
with this turnout you knock this hoe
from a library
from crow or some [ __ ] wall my son
[ __ ] got the whole number
and booed the whole you know what i'm
saying and then
you flip the script out [ __ ] you plead
with me
you see what i'm saying you see the
betrayal and the whole hall you see what
i'm saying
so the game has changed a lot man from
when i first from
from when i went in to now i was a
drastic change you know with this
technology
you know like she thinks she's space
agent
you know what i'm saying like and the
penalties are worse too right you know i
mean
you know they're white man you know what
i said man i prefer the shadow of my
you know what i'm saying this anomaly
right here this ain't something i
normally do
you feeling like real talk like this
ain't something i normally do
you know i'm saying like no cap like on
my soul like
i would have walked right past your way
you know what i'm saying heading out my
whole kind and told
what was going on you know what i'm
saying really advanced for you
you know what i'm saying man look man
you're able to get robbed or something
you know what i'm saying that's what i'm
doing so
i've been robbed before yeah i believe
you know what i'm saying
i believe bro you know what i was saying
but you know it pimping slaying my
once i told you my the slayer don't come
out to that and come out you know what
i'm saying so
what kind of girl what kind of qualities
do you look for in a girl well
you know i try to stay drool free but
see nat you know you got
sick pills too man you know what i'm
saying you got sex chasing that
hoes too you know what i'm saying they
see a [ __ ]
you know i'm saying supply they drool
you know what i'm saying and my yeah you
could pimp their way but then that's
that [ __ ] ain't no longevity you know
what i'm saying i'm trying to mine
last you know what i don't know it ain't
about what you get out here man it's
about
who lays the longest night you feel i
just done 10 years three months
you know i'm saying i ain't trying to
put myself in no compromise situation
come on then pee
you know how this [ __ ] gonna go you know
what i'm saying you might have to kill a
[ __ ] you might get cute you know
you got to think like that you got to
prepare yourself
for the worst situations out here in
these streets you know what i'm saying
especially dealing with women you feel
like emotional they did it the
emotions run so high you know what i'm
saying intrigues me
my have you ever seen a tunnel i vision
treatment
they
[Music]
had did one [ __ ] nine baby white [ __ ]
from kentucky young [ __ ] you know what
i was saying
i'm 33 she was probably i'm 33
now this one i was 20. she probably
would 33 then
viet hope being in the game you know
what i'm saying will you call the shirt
the temp shoes head they're blowing her
with the ring
clear thick little white [ __ ] yeah i'm
talking about whoo
my tricks used to go [ __ ] crazy for
these hoe
like no cap i'm telling like
mine is one tree man we used to call
them frank yeah
these don't do nothing to eat hot dogs
all day you know
mine freaked the [ __ ] out yeah one of
them old finish hey
dude want a [ __ ] want to hold it
lick his ass and [ __ ] him in the ass and
just freak the [ __ ] out but he got that
old taste type [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
he either want a chocolate chocolate ass
[ __ ] or you want one of these old
church looking a's white girl
i'm saying screaming i'll put a mail
ring on my pinky finger come
here to the game man solid gold ring man
with this [ __ ] but they treat one
timeout [ __ ] up about bailly he wants
the only one [ __ ] up about baby
you know what i'm saying but they get
their [ __ ] they get that scene and they
know man they they don't want
none it don't come out man go crazy like
if the whole pokemon don't want to suck
their dick or don't want to perform
whatever [ __ ] up they perverted
they won't perform why they lose it i
just told you to buy the trick they
tried
mine put the [ __ ] out man don't tell me
i'll book the [ __ ] without paying a
[ __ ] you know my whole gangsta so she
up their pocket knife on them you know
what i'm saying
yeah but that cj my whole got a gash in
her leg beating my goddamn feast
you know what i'm saying my momma doctor
and on this whole right now you know
how big a part of of this life
is stealing the the trick's
jewelry his wallet his whatever see this
instead of just sex for money oh i'm
saying see they're low bar when you're
dealing with these little street walking
and flat backing there [ __ ] you know
it ain't no telling what you're gonna
get
you know what i'm saying hoe might not
be a hoe she might be a bro
you need to you need a chit chick you
know what i'm saying
but you know i try to you know stay in
the casinos mine you know what i'm
saying
and then mine you know we trapping off
every little social site my instagram
mine facebook messenger of mine
mine mine mine snapchat mine by the way
my audi wheels like mine
looking for nothing my big show win
big show win man yeah and that's all
they want man you know what i'm saying
is that all about the pimp man how you
how you present the whole and it's
enough
and then see you got to have a whole
gang tight too so the pimp
pimping got a schooly [ __ ] man you know
what i'm saying when you're dealing with
a whole
minded don't just know too much mine you
know you got to walk with the you got
you got to you got to walk
hand in hand with your [ __ ] in a sense
until the whole you know what i'm saying
get up and running or you could put a
big [ __ ] with the bc
don't never two of the same hoes
you see what i'm saying if you knock
this hoe and she fresh and you'll stay
don't put her with no another green egg
hole you just knock this fresh in your
state but they got too much income in my
you hoes will break bad with this breed
you're in my whole ain't gonna never
leave bro
a whole ain't gonna never leave bro you
see what i'm saying
yeah it's so mighty too hoe they got too
much income
fresh you see what i'm saying new to the
stable ain't just got the ends and now
damn the pet man they got more breaking
them
do they then they got breaking on you
yeah when they got breaking news they
gonna run you
they got breaking down and they gonna
pay you see what i'm saying i don't know
how they gonna pay and stay man you know
what i'm saying all the issues [ __ ]
might look cool you had it
yeah they want them broke a [ __ ] rock
sitting there [ __ ] around the corner
they won't
you know what i'm saying how come i lit
a whole nother top well i don't need you
i'm going to leave word for feeds
straight like that you know what i'm
saying the day you lit up hold the day
you can get gone man
you know what i'm saying when your money
gone get going with it you know what i'm
saying
straight like that how much your girls
making tonight you know
my bottom [ __ ] you know seeing just too
much for sale for say cuz she
handle all my other little endeavors you
know what i'm saying so
you know she worked primarily you know
i'm saying that whole brain in like 1500
here two weeks though so she paying her
weight
you know what i'm saying but she just
ain't earning it like my other hoes
earned and i'm talking about i gotta
walk them out and earn a path [ __ ]
with me you know what i'm saying so
you know with my other three whole my
try to you know
temper on my like fast 600 a night you
know what i'm saying on a good night
like two three thousand you know what
i'm saying
we got some good tricks you know what
i'm saying i got some boy be calling for
mississippi
and in jackson tennessee and she'd be
spending like a month for
you know saying country boy they just
want to smoke they cracked it they did
so
you know what i'm saying then you know
we got to eat look
have bad tricks in the casino you know
what i'm saying you dial your [ __ ]
you know i'm saying put a little bit put
a little money in the [ __ ] you know i
was ain't having looking like some
presentable
you know i'm saying i don't want no old
snack or two-face
hang neal [ __ ] walking up beside me man
i just jumped out of 2016. you see that
white journey out there man you know
what i'm saying
like yeah ho you got to look like me how
you representing me a reflection of me
how you going to be off the paul
you know what i'm saying and mine you
know
with it mine it it it kind of dictate
the truth that you went that you were
tricked you know what i'm saying so
you know you can't catch a shawl with a
worm you feel
so you got to put the appropriate bait
out for you know who you want so
if i'm around like a corporation or
something you know i'm gonna have my
whole always
depart my design without the label you
know what i'm saying
yeah my real sophisticated ascii you
know what i'm saying
you know i'm saying i could clean them
nice talk they talk walk they walk
myself i just
you know i'm a gang baby i'm a street
[ __ ] my tattoos all
over my mind you know what i'm saying
murder charges on my jack you know i was
in so
you know hoping to get through certain
dogs that i can't you know what i'm
saying so i let the whole dragon call
certain situations and [ __ ] but the
whole hallway directed by you know you
know what i'm saying
you know i was in for it how to be it
was a tale of everybody remember that
you know what i'm saying yeah so you
know the whole be
knowing a good start good lookers and
[ __ ] but mine look hoe
man you lost without direction you see
what i'm saying even a [ __ ] hoe need a
good pimp
you know what i'm saying you know so the
price is
they're probably very man you know what
i'm saying you know these hoes that hurt
me to [ __ ] the game up anyway my sucking
dick for 20's and fallings and [ __ ] man
nah this [ __ ]
when i got out my got out in july of
mine i got out the pentaton
i was trapping in the penitentiary you
know what i'm saying i went on no broke
[ __ ] in the penitentiary
you know it's pimping at home going on
enough
you know what i'm saying for real talk
real talk you know what i'm saying i
ain't no no homo [ __ ] i let them boy be
the boy man you know what i'm saying
yeah this is the big boy league
i'm saying so you know what i'm saying
we knocking guards
sergeants i'm saying yeah yeah we
[ __ ] the corporal and we [ __ ]
corporal in the broom claws type [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
making the whole running stick you know
what i'm saying getting out of breathe
out the segment you know what they pay
fit that all for on the weed out here
man they paid 200 [ __ ] g
yeah well then so boom this whole like
me
whatever like how i talk how i look my
dreads out it all
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying anything i
need to check the whole you know what
i'm saying see if i hold like you got
one foot in the game
all right you know what i'm saying this
on you behind it is that that's an
important part of the
relationship right the girl has to like
you she got to respect you
see what i'm saying like just a luxury
you know
i'm sure one of them i'm sure i'm sure
my whole don't like me
you know what i'm saying but they ain't
seen enough you feel me
they know not to play you see what i'm
saying yeah they know not to play
my my mind a [ __ ] fast for out here in
the street you know i said it got to be
a level of love
you just you see what i'm saying or or
deep in fashion wait whatever you want
to call it whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call it they got to beat it you know
what i'm saying
the whole got to have some type of
inclination tools you might have to like
how you talk what you write what you
saying what you doing who you around
some you see what i'm saying for her to
do what she do for you
you see what i'm saying no
it's like mine imagine
imagining a mama video baby
in the house catch on fire
yo what she gonna do
she gonna run up black ass in there and
fight flames for that baby
here that's how powerful love you yeah
yeah hoes called hole called a pimp
daddy
you see what i'm saying i'm they purring
you in a sense you know what i'm saying
yeah i ain't making but you're my baby
you know what i'm saying
so i just got to love you and then this
same sense man look i ain't taking
nobody word over my whole
you know what i'm saying yeah it can't
no trick telling me number no whole
can't know what a hotel you know about
my whole unless
yeah my whole could tell me something
about my other hoe yeah
because what's she there for keep this
whole uh um
on her toes yeah hit these hoes against
each other
i don't i don't curl them up i put them
against each other you see what i'm
saying
yeah i might tell this red [ __ ] why i
like
look you see what i'm saying in her mind
her song
conscious this is what i like i don't
like her
so now she trying to earn it you feel
she gonna work a little bit hard a
little bit smaller
you know what i'm saying and then what
you want to do man you want to pop the
leash man you feel
i was saying pop the whip screw me man
you already got a leash around the whole
[ __ ] you want to pop it with
your vehicle make the whole work you
feel well i'm saying
i gotta have a motivation you know
what's ain't that why i say a whole got
to feel like she a part of something
powerful
i don't want to work for no ranking
thinking [ __ ] yeah
come on man i hope i'll be broke by
myself you see what i'm saying
right they busted their head beat brewed
by myself
i want to put a little form man you know
what i'm saying glowing man you know
what i'm saying
yeah i was saying you can't present it
that way
look you anyway you know what i'm saying
and that ain't never been me man i i
i shoot for the i shoot for the top you
know what i'm saying
my older hoe my my second hoe i was in
jail and when they got the gas in the
lead
fine you're fine fine
yeah you want to not think this whole
sucking and [ __ ] the way she is for
the cage
yeah real talk i was like you got to
have a whole mind
[ __ ] blend in in a different circle
right because you don't want to do
local joking [ __ ] going to keep you
local joe going to keep you broke man
i'm on some big money [ __ ] i want mines
and clumps
you feel so i gotta up the enema you
know what i'm saying got to do it a
little bit different think outside the
box man
make my own niche you see what i'm
saying yeah so my whole got all the
talents too man
feeling like boosting it doing hurry
you know what i'm saying frog you know
what i'm saying yeah am i
making making [ __ ] fake fake credentials
at these
you know what i'm saying g g d i got a
whole mind
i gotta hold right now mine that'll make
an id
for any state any [ __ ] state i
want to go in
yeah yeah you gotta have a whole day you
know
multitality man you know what i'm saying
come on get what man you going all the
[ __ ] stuff for so long man
yeah yeah man they [ __ ] where out well
i'm saying
yeah i saw you if you wanna you know
what i'm saying keep it keep the whole
one you know what i'm saying have a
little bit more
you know i'm saying longevity that's all
about how you market the whole
you feel you know i ain't gonna send no
street walker
up in the corporate city i'm gonna be
out of enemy i ain't gonna know how to
come to the trees ain't gonna know how
to check the tricks or not
you hear me and then there it is i'm
gonna be frustrated i'm gonna beat the
beat so i'm gonna do something up you
feel i'm gonna have to go
you know i said do something that i
wouldn't have to do if i would
probably put this [ __ ] together you see
what i'm saying pimping to mine hey
listen man
for for for for something so simple mine
mine it's so complicated you feel we
just make it look easy you see what i'm
saying because it's out of life
you feel if you don't know the rule to
the game then why you playing you see
what i'm saying
so me mine i tried to get around you
know
other my my pimps deal with mine that i
seen then there's a thing about pyramid
too mine
don't just let [ __ ] in a circle
you see what i'm saying
see i'm blessed in the city in the in
the sense that
i come from like you know i'm saying
like
a rural family you see what i'm saying
like
like i told you like my mom a big [ __ ]
popping in the hood like
everybody know you know what i'm saying
you know i said my big brother
or real gangster in the fields right now
you know what i'm saying
yeah it beat two bodies you know what
i'm saying like a real gangster like he
the reason i'm against right now you
know i'm saying i'm proud to say that
you know what i'm saying
but we did like
i already had like you know what i'm
saying
certain little you know we call them
pimp bones you know what i'm saying
i just like ain't got a pimp on anybody
he'll sin
yeah i come from a thoroughbred family
so it was already
you know what i'm saying upbringing once
i when pops got cute
was i came back to my mom mine it was
streets 101. you know what i'm saying
pimping hoods and rob and mine
finishing my frog mine whatever you
could think of
mine sharon renee who's had a hand in
the pipeline had a hand in that job man
you know what i'm saying and you know me
man i'm proud to say this my mama you
know i was saying i was proud to say my
this is what we doing
you know what i'm saying you know and
i went about the whole day i dealt with
what i'm saying from what i was told you
see what i'm saying so
i say my a whole got the compliment you
you see what i'm saying you know i know
what's the
what's the [ __ ] use i have and i hope
this peter there's gonna be a conflict
and entry every time you turn around
this whole got something to say
they hope we got some victor this whole
ain't come to hawaii me nick
come on man i'm straight hold what i
need you around you know i can do bad by
myself
keep rocks yeah and me i'm blunt rude
in a sense i tell the whole seat that's
another thing too man you got to be
unapologetic and you dope in the pimp
game man
v my what i say what i mean man
oh you can suck my d from the back if
you think you know any other thing you
feel
you know it's all about the pimp baby
i'm saying
yeah my my life real my my struggle real
no i'm saying anything a [ __ ]
want to know man they could google this
[ __ ] man this [ __ ] black and white man
well i'm saying i lost a partner i don't
know this [ __ ] the truth
you feel you all right super interesting
first soul good luck with everything
stay out of prison for so man
take care of your girls i appreciate
their home
it's a wrap it's a high fridge oh
day way